oh
so
so
hey
okay
it's always scary we don't want to be
the one
china
hey
is
[Music]
good news
i feel safe for talking with you again
you don't want to wear that though
thank you
that's very good
hello everyone
is
yes
factory
oh
oh
seven minutes
now
in a few minutes
foreign
oh
two minute warning on the first briefing
two minute or so
thank you
oh my god
uh
um
okay happy monday uh i know we have a
busy afternoon for all of you so we will
try to get through as many
questions as we can possibly get through
i just have two
items for you at the top this morning
the white house
we released 50 state by state fact
sheets in addition to fact sheets for
puerto rico and the district of columbia
laying out the critical necessity of
passing the american jobs plan
so we can invest in vital infrastructure
create good paying jobs and grow
our economy on the screens behind me
you'll see
some of the needs outlined and the
tangible difference the jobs plan will
make in improving
the lives of americans so just to for a
few highlights here
from 2010 to 2020 florida has
experienced 22 extreme
weather events costing the state up to
100 billion dollars in damages the
president is calling for 50 billion
dollars to improve the resiliency of our
infrastructure of course there are many
states across the country
that have had weather events and have
been impacted but this is just one of
the examples
in michigan there are more than 1200
bridges and over 7 300 miles of highway
in poor conditions that's clearly an
area that could benefit
from funding including the 115 billion
dollars repairing for repairing roads
and bridges
uh in the plan in south dakota 13
percent
uh of south dakotans do not have access
to acceptable broadband speeds that's
something we'd love to improve
why there's a hundred billion dollars to
propose uh to bring
universal reliable high speed and
affordable coverage to every
family and in nevada finally 243 000
renters spend more than 30 percent of
their income on rent
one of the reasons we've proposed a
president has proposed investing over
200 billion to increase
housing supply so these are they're
state by state you should all have them
uh but what they really do is identify
the needs in these states and how
uh this package could be uh could
benefit as we've talked about it bit in
here
there are different types of funding for
infrastructure that would be worked
through with congress
as the the discussions proceed finally i
also wanted to highlight a significant
win for american workers in the
american auto industry over the weekend
late saturday night into sunday morning
as you know a key part of the
president's buildback better
plan includes a significant increase in
the number of electric vehicles and
batteries built here in america
we need a strong diversified and
resilient us-based electric
vehicle battery supply chain so we can
meet the growing
global demand for these vehicles and
components and the settlement we
announced over the weekend
or i should say was announced by ustr
and others by sk innovation and lg
is a positive step that builds
confidence in their reliability and
responsibility as suppliers to the u.s
auto industry it's great news for many
people in the country including people
of georgia and other states that are
impacted a great deal
by uh this issue with that alex kick us
off
thanks jen um i wanted to ask about the
attack on iran's nikon's nuclear
facility
uh is there concern within the white
house that this will derail ongoing
talks to establish
the iran nuclear deal and has there been
any effort by the administration to
reach out through
intermediaries or any other way to run
and make clear that the us wasn't
involved in these attacks
in the attack well i we of course have
seen the reports of the incident
at the natanz enrichment facility the us
was not involved
in any manner we have nothing to add on
speculation about the causes
or the impacts i will say on your first
question though uh
we are focused on the discussions that
we expect to proceed
this wednesday in vienna uh to the
diplomatic discussions
that are that have been taking place and
took place last week they were
we expect them to be difficult and long
we've not been given any indication
about a change in participation for
these discussions
with respect to the semiconductor summit
um are there any actions
the white house or the federal
government can take immediately to
address the chip
shortage or you know is this just the
kind of thing that you
you need reforms and more funding for
and then does the president see the
shortage as a national security issue
uh we certainly do i will say there are
a number of steps
that we believe we can take as a federal
government
we believe there needs to be a holistic
long-term
across government approach uh in the
near term
we're engaging with industry as is
evidenced by the meeting that's taking
place
shortly later this afternoon as well as
our international partners to ensure
that american companies are operating
on an even playing field uh even before
uh
this global this meeting today i should
say
we have also proposed major investments
that's something we feel the federal
government could also do
we've proposed we called on congress to
invest 50 billion dollars in
semiconductor manufacturing and research
as called for in the bipartisanship act
we have also called for additional
funding
um there's also bipartisan proposals i
should say like an investment of 50
billion in the national science
foundation which would create a techno
technology directorate that will focus
on fields like semiconductors and
advanced computing to help increase our
competitiveness at home
so our view is that this is certainly
something where
we need to work closely with industry we
need to work closely with congress
democrats and republicans there's
agreement on this issue
being one that's impacting industries
across the country also with allies and
partners and how we can prevent
uh this shortage from happening in the
future go ahead
and thank you jen um just to follow up
on the church shortage
uh and sort of short-term solutions um
any any conversations perhaps with two
manufacturers
like for example samsung to prioritize
u.s borders for automakers
or you know any thoughts on perhaps
getting rid of regulations
that'll help uh keep keeping supplies
for automakers
any any sense of what you can do now
well one of the reasons the president is
stopping by this meeting that our
national security advisor and
nec director holding this afternoon is
to hear directly
from companies about the impacts what
would help the most through this period
of time and the shortage that
as you all have reported on has impacted
a range of industries across the country
so
this isn't a meeting where we expect a
decision or an announcement to come out
of but
part of our ongoing engagement and
discussion about how to best address
this
issue over the long term but also over
the short term okay and
a couple questions on immigration we
understand that there was
a an agreement with honduras
mexico and guatemala to place more
troops at the border
um and we understand that the vice
president was able to secure these
commitments and
have seen some numbers on uh you know
how many troops will be placed at these
borders
but when were these when were these
agreements struck and if you can just
give us any sense of
what this plan really entails well there
have been a series of bilateral
discussions between our leadership in
the regional governments of mexico
honduras
and guatemala through those discussions
there was a commitment as
you mentioned to increase border
security
so mexico made the decision to maintain
10 000 troops at its southern border
resulting in twice as many daily migrant
interdictions
guatemala surged 1500 police and
military personnel to its southern
border with honduras
and agreed to set up 12 checkpoints
along the migratory route honduras
surged 7
000 police and military to disperse a
large contingent of migrants
as with any diplomatic discussion these
discussions happen at several
levels and certainly as you know we have
an
envoy who has discussions with the
region we've had roberta jacobson
working for a
period of time to help have these
discussions with the region
about what steps can be taken to help
reduce the number of migrants who are
coming
to the u.s mexico border characterize it
as
these agreements were struck recently i
mean and in the past few weeks would it
be fair to say that
i think that's that's fair to say but i
would also say that they often these
discussions
are ongoing over a period of time and
take place at
several levels of uh the government both
here and within these countries
and is the plan to sort of apprehend
these migrants who were trying to cross
the border
or sort of as they're already on their
way to the united states is the plan to
sort of you know
stop them there how will this work you'd
have to
speak with these countries about how
they will be implementing i think the
objective is to make it
more difficult to make the journey and
make crossing the borders more more
difficult
okay thank you go ahead kelly on
minnesota
and another officer-involved shooting
that resulted in the death of an
african-american man
has the white house been in touch with
governor walls or are there any
resources from the federal government
that are being offered and this comes at
a time when obviously the shogun trial
is progressing is there a federal plan
for
when that trial reaches its conclusion
whatever the outcome may be
um and thirdly i'm racing through them
because we're short on time today
the president had promised as a
candidate a police commission
that dr rice says will not go forward at
this time
uh it seems obviously that officer
involved
interactions with the public are
intensely important at the moment
so first on minnesota if you could
address the police commission sure and
just check me if i don't get to all of
your questions i will try to do my best
uh
when we first say that we are incredibly
saddened uh we were incredibly excited
to hear about the loss of life the hands
of law enforcement in minnesota
yesterday
the president has of course been briefed
he'll have a few words he will share at
the top of the semiconductor event that
will be
starting shortly hence we'll be moving
through our questions here
about his own thoughts uh we are also in
touch with the governor in touch with
the mayor
in touch with local enforcement law
enforcement authorities
as well i would say it is a reminder
of the pain the anger the trauma the
exhaustion
that many communities across the country
have felt as we see
these incidents continue to occur
within just a few miles of uh of
where the tragic events happened just a
year ago uh
in terms of the police commission um we
have been in very close contact over the
course of several months back to the
transition
with both civil rights activists with
law enforcement
authorities and the law enforcement
community about what would be most
effective moving forward
and as dr uh rice uh conveyed or i think
the statement we put out i should say
uh conveyed uh we have made a decision
in quotation that the best path forward
is to work with the path
to uh pass the george flow uh policing
act
that that has a great deal of content
of the policy changes of the necessary
rooms
uh that we will put in place so that was
a collective decision and that's where
our food will be
is this a delay or do you expect it to
just not go forward
well we expect uh for the time being for
focusing on moving the legislation
forward and not on the policing
commission
you mentioned you know the focus is now
on passing the george ford policing act
it's been over a month we've heard the
president talk about this we haven't
seen a big bush
should we expect to see this sort of
rise on the list of your priorities you
obviously have a very
full plate we do uh but i would say that
uh the president
was addressing racial equity
ensuring that we are putting in place
long overdue
reforms real change is a priority for
him it is something he
looks forward to continuing to discuss
with members of congress
he believes that there is a path forward
that this piece of legislation offers
that
path forward and he certainly will use
uh the power of his presidency to move
it forward
that civil rights groups recommended
against this commission did they put
forth other recommendations steps that
the white house can take
while you try and pressure congress wait
and hope that the senate will act on
them
well we of course are in very close
touch with them i think what is
uh in i should say more specifically
we've been in touch with um
a range of groups including the naacp
legal defense fund
the leadership con congress conference
i'm sorry
as well as leading experts and the
strong consensus from all of these
groups is that
the work should be focused on trying to
pass the george flight act and the
commission would not be the most
constructive way to deliver on our top
priority so we are working together
collectively to do
exactly that there are steps that we
certainly
will work in conjunction to take as as
as they are possible
and some of them we've signed through
executive orders and we'll continue to
communicate with these groups about what
is most effective
on infrastructure the president is
having this bipartisan meeting today
but what is your message to some
congressional republicans who have
expressed skepticism about whether
the white house is authentically
interested in negotiating here given
how things played out with the current
relief bill well i would say that
the president you don't use the
president of the united states his time
multiple times over including two
infrastructure meetings bipartisan
infrastructure meetings he's already had
or the meeting today if he did not want
to authentically hear
from the members attending about their
ideas about how to
move forward this package in a
bipartisan manner so is he willing to
negotiate on the scope in the price tag
or just
on ways to pay for this he absolutely is
he looks forward to hearing their ideas
uh and his objective is to find a way
forward where we can modernize our
nation's infrastructure so we can
compete
with china he's proposed a way to pay
for it which is
what he thinks the responsible thing is
to do and he hopes they'll come to the
table with ideas
uh go ahead josh let me get asked for an
update uh on march 18th he said that
there was a stockpile of seven million
astrazeneca doses some of which were
loaned to canadians and mexicans
current number and say whether the
president is considering sending more
either those countries or
uh other countries uh i don't have
anything to predict in terms of uh
sharing the stockpile at this point i
can assure you that uh we don't want
that stockpile to
uh expire uh and obviously we don't have
control over
the fda approval process but i don't
have anything more to preview for you at
this point
the first majors that are in that
stockpile
i'm happy to check for you josh and see
if there's more we can share and
astrazeneca themselves of course could
share more details probably
does let us know whether any us-made
shots have left u.s soil other than
those loans in other words shots made
on u.s soil but not for the us
government from the companies
correct so can companies sell export
currently as long as they're meeting
their us obligations i think that's a
question about their contracts obviously
we
and we've had this discussion before
there's an obligation under certain
contracts to deliver on the
commitments made in the contract with
the us government especially when
the defense production act has been uh
invoked
but i would send you the companies for
that question that's just a couple of
personnel things you mentioned roberta
jacobson
why did she make the decision to step
down from
that post and can you say whether it's
accurate that cindy mccain is being
considered for the u.n food ambassador
program post
sure on the first i would say it was
always ambassador jacobson's intention
to stay for about a hundred days she's
been a
diplomat uh serving in a range of roles
around the world from ambassador to
mexico to
assistant secretary for wha for decades
and she is retiring and she deserves uh
as she has certainly
uh done her that paid her time to do and
so that was always her intention to stay
for a period of time
in that period of time of course we have
also announced
the uh naming of a an envoy ricardo
ziniga who
has played a prominent role uh in the
western hemisphere in the past for the
us government
he'll be playing that role the
president's asked the vice president to
play
an elevated role in engagement and
negotiations with the northern triangle
hence our earlier discussion about
her role there and the the path forward
there uh so there are a range of
officials who will continue to do this
work
we were fortunate to have the work and
the expertise and experience of
ambassador jacobson as long as we have
uh
there is an ongoing process on
ambassadors i know that there's a lot of
eager
eagerness and interest in learning more
it's ongoing the president has not made
the decision about the major vast
majority of his ambassadorial
nominations thank you go ahead thanks
jen
um president biden has made very clear
that two of his top priorities for the
infrastructure plan
is to create jobs and to stimulate the
economy
last night on 60 minutes jerome powell
said he and other forecasters already
see that happening so i wonder if the
optimistic outlook
changes the president's priorities in
the plan at all
and offers more wiggle room for
negotiation in certain areas
do you mean to to we don't need as many
jobs
you know the goal of the plan is to
create jobs and stimulate the income
and they're saying that's already
happening which is a great thing
so is he willing to scale back on some
of these
items because we're already seeing
growth well i i unfortunately i
regularly watch 60 minutes i did not see
the whole episode so i don't know the
whole context of his
uh remarks but i will say that uh part
of what economists
feel is that we are still behind that we
need to still do more
because if you look at our last jobs
report it was we were still about 8.4
million jobs
uh in the red you know that we needed to
create that we needed to
uh to uh you know americans we need to
put back to work
there are still parts of the american
population
high levels of unemployment among
african americans latino americans
asian americans that we need to work to
address this is definitely a jobs
package hence the american jobs plan but
what it also
does is it helps modernize invest in our
nation's infrastructure
and do that in a way that will help us
compete over the long term and
help us have jobs for the future so
there are many objectives of this
package
but certainly we feel there is more work
to be done to put more americans back to
work
and we are we are not in the clear on
that front thank you and on the
state-by-state fact sheets that you
released this morning
can you just share how that process
happened including who was involved in
putting together the state by state
reports
and what the metrics were to assign that
you know final grade for each state
well it was done by a collection of
smart and brilliant people on our
economic
team that you probably wouldn't
necessarily identify on the streets but
sounds like a good profile piece to me
um
but you know they work to identify what
the needs are in the states i don't know
that i have the exact
process to outline for you but maybe you
can work with state
officials and local um departments as
well
to to decide what each state needs what
the needs are
i'm happy to check and see if there's
more about the process that we can share
okay
sure go ahead yes you talking about
paying for the infrastructure bill is
the president set on raising the
corporate
tax rate as a way to do that even though
republicans are saying it's a red line
or is that also open to negotiation
it's all open to negotiation but i will
say that
raising having corporations pay more
pay their fair share uh raising the rate
to a rate that is still
lower than it has been aside from a few
years since the world war
ii president feels is an entirely
reasonable
appropriate effective way to pay for
this package
there are other proposals that have been
put out there including
user fees a president doesn't feel that
we should pay for this package on the
backs of the american people but he's
certainly eager to hear
ideas from democrats and republicans on
alternatives senator john cornyn called
joe biden's tweets unimaginably
conventional and said that his comments
were
largely scripted and questioned whether
he was really in charge the white house
doesn't have any reaction
to that well i can confirm that the
president of the united states does not
spend his time
tweeting conspiracy theories he spends
his time working on behalf of the
american people
go ahead oh go ahead uh oh josh you went
what
help me hurry up go ahead so just to
piggyback off of on the corporate tax
rate senator manchin said that
he only is worth raising it to 25 that
that's
his line in the stand what's the white
house response to that and has
the president or secretary voted spoken
to mention about the corporate sector
well we're in regular touch with a range
of officials senators members of
congress
there have been dozens and dozens of
meetings and briefings i don't have a
specific
readout of our engagements with senator
manchin i'm sure he could share that
with all of you
but i would say that we're certainly
encouraged to hear that senator manchin
is open to raising the corporate tax
rate as a means of potentially paying
for
a historic investment in our nation's
infrastructure and most importantly to
creating jobs
and the president is happy to hear ideas
or alternatives for how
this plan and package could should be
paid for his primary focus
is on this investment on creating jobs
on
helping put back to work the millions of
uh
men and women who don't have college
degrees on ensuring we're
evening the playing field on doing what
we can to compete with china over the
long term
there are disagreements about how to pay
for it we're happy to have a discussion
about
that and then two more quickly there
appears to be a large deployment of
russian land forces towards the border
with ukraine what is the administration
prepared to do
if russia moves in being eastern ukraine
well first let me say we are um
concerned as i've said uh in the past
but we've been of course watching it
over the course of the weekend
about um the increasing aggression of uh
russian uh forces on the border uh
secretary blinken and secretary austin
are in brussels
this week meeting with their i'm sure
this will be a topic of
uh discussion we also remain in touch
with ukrainian officials at a range of
levels but
i'm not going to get ahead of their
discussions that they're having on the
ground
just on police reform again the you
mentioned on friday that the president
is meeting with cbc
tomorrow is police reform going to be
the topic of discussion criminal justice
reform what exactly will they be
discussing sure there'll be a range of
issues discussed the
primary purpose from our perspective is
to discuss the american jobs plan
and how to move that forward but as is
always the case there will be a range of
topics we expect discussed during the
meeting
do we have to gather 12 45 i think it's
one o'clock
12 55. okay 10 more minutes alex is so
responsible for keeping track
she is she is yeah go ahead go ahead
when can we expect to see the president
uh announce the american family plan
that would just be coming soon
when do you look for that also there's
some talk about making the expanded
child care tax credit permanent
uh or is the commission looking at
extending it or making it permanent at
this point
so uh the president believes there's a
hugely huge benefit
of the child tax credit that's why he
put the child tax credit in his
uh in his aarp american rescue plan uh
because he feels it's important it's
vital help get the two million women who
are
out of work um back to work hopefully
back into the workforce
expect you'll hear more on the american
families plan in the coming weeks but i
don't have an exact date for you quite
yet
nothing on whether or not the
administration consider making it
permanent or just attending it
i don't have anything more to preview
for you on the american family's plan
although
just to reiterate the president believes
the child tax credit is
a way to help american families and
especially uh
all of the working moms out there who
are trying to make ends meet go ahead
right yeah go ahead so i want to call
off on a question i asked i feel like
it's
a month ago now it may have been the new
york times left it down with the story
that mississippi uh was having a hard
time
getting folks vaccinated but it's not
just um
mississippi it's a bunch of other rural
states ohio
oklahoma there are 34 um
vaccination rate even so opening up
vaccines to
out the staters i know we talked a
little bit about before
the preliminary steps because the white
house get in touch with these governors
to see what they can do now because of
course this impacts for immunity
and the goals of the white house just to
get these shots in on
well there are a number of steps that
we've taken in the recent weeks uh
including
launching the community corps which is
our program to provide fact-based
messages
into the hands of local messengers so
we've now we're now working with more
than
4000 organizations that have signed up
so far
across the country including in a number
of the states that you mentioned
we're also investing three billion
dollars to states and community-based
organizations to strengthen vaccine
confidence in the highest risk and
hardest hit
communities and often people uh think of
that as just black and brown communities
and that is not as you've noted that is
also
conservative communities white
evangelicals it's a range of communities
around the country
what we found to be most effective is to
work with these local organizations so
faith-based organizations community
health organizations civic leaders and
others who can really get this message
deeply in communities we've also had a
number of
our members of our coveted team from dr
fauci
and for and dr collins participate
as an example participate in a range of
media interviews
you know an example is dr collins
participated in the 700 club
dr nunes smith hosted a faith leaders
roundtable
we're also looking for we've run psas on
the deadliest catch
we're engaged with nascar and country
music tv we're looking for a range of
creative ways to
get directly connected to white
conservative communities we won't always
be the best
messengers but we're still trying to
meet people where they are but also
empower local organizations
and just like follow up to you does the
white house endorse these states opening
up their vaccines to folks i'm out of
state you know these
these do expire so it's rather than them
sitting on the shelf they're good to go
to somebody else
well these states are all going to have
their own implementation plans and we
certainly work with them to advise
how to distribute the vaccines most as
equitably as possibly
as possible and as effectively and
efficiently around states
no state is 100 vaccinated as as we know
so our focus has been working with them
on how to get them to the communities
that are the hardest hit
uh go ahead go ahead sorry go ahead and
go to go ahead
thanks um so why haven't president biden
signed the presidential
determination that would lift former
president trump's uh
immigration policies including the 15
000 refugee cap
it's uh issue he remains committed to as
he announced i just don't have an update
on the signing of the paperwork
okay i equity was cited as the reason
for which the white house
decided against surging factions for
michigan
the administration is searching fema
vaccinators
what makes the vaccine different i would
say
i think it's important to understand how
we've approached vaccine distribution
from the beginning
uh it's done uh with equity in mind it's
done
with uh the state the population the
adult population in mind
we don't pick uh by our friends we don't
pick through a political prism
we pick through what is most effective
to be fair and equitable around the
country
we also made an announcement during the
transition that we were not going to
hold on to a big supply we distribute
and get the supply out as quickly as
possible
so that's why our focus is on working
with
states like michigan to you know search
testing
search tracing search the distribution
of therapeutics
areas where we have the ability to
provide additional help additional
resources
but we're not in a place nor will we be
and where we take supply from one state
to give it to another
go ahead follow up on brittany's
question about vaccines
do you think that the white house has
had any part in this in having
sort of maybe pessimistic message
towards some americans who are skeptical
of this administration who for partisan
reasons or otherwise
to see vaccinated people in the cabinet
or the president continuing to wear
masks around each other
or hearing that things won't be back to
normal as the vaccine continues to be
distributed
do you think that that is having a
negative effect at all
on people make sure i understand your
question are people not taking the
vaccine yeah of people who are scheduled
vaccine
and uh who don't trust the body
administration
well look i think one we recognize we're
not always the best messengers that's
why we're working with these local
organizations and groups because we
certainly know that
president biden and vice president
harris may not be the right voices in a
range of communities across the country
two we believe that part of our
objective is to
model public health guidelines and that
means continuing to wear masks
continuing to
hand wash social distance uh because
they're still ongoing research on what
is most effective how to prevent
distribution and it uh that the sorry
the pandemic
traveling further so i'm not sure i'm
understanding your question
how do you um how do you strike that
balance between
being a model of the health guidelines
that's also contributing to this sense
of hopelessness perhaps
among people who are skeptical of your
vaccine and maybe feel like getting it
would not make a difference in their
lives anyway
sure yeah i think a big part of what
we're trying to do is provide
accurate information about what getting
a vaccine will enable
the american people to do hence the
president gave a prime time address
where he said
if when you get the vac if you when the
vaccine's accessible to you and you get
it
we can work towards having backyard
barbecues uh
we've also had a number of officials out
there to convey and we've had obviously
the cdc has put out guidance that says
if you're vaccinated if your neighbors
are vaccinated
you can have dinner inside together it's
a pandemic we don't think it's
easy we know it's difficult it's
required a lot of sacrifice
but at the same time we're trying to
provide accurate
public health-based guidance on what
people can do once they have uh
taken the vaccine go ahead in the back
thank you very much
jen um two is a question okay um
on john kerry's visit to potential visit
to
shanghai what's president biden's
expectation of that
of john kerry's visit well certainly
he'll be focused on
discussing climate and how we can work
with leaders around the region to
get control of our the climate crisis
but i would send you to the state
department because they
uh that's where he works and also on the
chief
summit according to south korea media
korea economic daily uh quote
industry watchers say following this
white house meeting
samsung may be forced to make
a decision on his new u.s factory sooner
and view the production line for
automotive
chips given the dire shortage of such
chiefs in the united states well i know
we'll put out a readout after the
meeting but the meeting the purpose of
the meeting is really to consult with
these business leaders about how we can
help
address the shortage let me just get
around to the back and then
go ahead um iran immigration
um on iran uh the foreign minister is
bowing revenge against
israel for its alleged attack on its
nuclear facilities
israel's not denied this how concerned
is the white house as the president with
the actions of an
ally potentially maybe derailing efforts
by the white house to get ron back into
compliance
under the jcpoa well i think i answered
a version of this question earlier but
let me try again uh
well again we've seen the reports uh we
don't have anything more to speak to as
it relates to the causes
or who is responsible our focus is of
course on the diplomatic path forward
uh we've not been given any indication
that attendance at the
discussions and the that will proceed on
wednesday has changed so that's where
our focus is
but is there concern that the actions of
an ally are derailing
i think i've answered your question did
you have another one i didn't think it
was an answer
okay i'm sorry to hear that i i've
answered it a couple times okay let me
just quickly follow up okay
let me try and ukraine the secretary of
state said that there will be
consequences
um if russia continues its escalation on
the border
can you give us a sense of what those
range of options are
and then also at what level does
this escalation require president biden
to
reach out to vladimir putin uh well i
would say that
what we've long said is that there will
be some consequences that are seen
and some that are unseen i'm not going
to give you a
a menu of the options when we're ready
to announce them
we will announce them and share the
details uh with all of you
very quickly on immigration okay um with
regard to the
um the militarization of the borders in
central america the agreements that have
been secured
did the white house in any way secure
any or is the white house concerned
given the record number of children that
have been making this track
that they are at greater risk given the
fact that these are soldiers not daycare
workers
well i think the objective is to deter
uh deter the journey and so that's why
our discussions with these countries
involved increasing law enforcement
capacity at the border
worry though about sort of this
increased militarization given i didn't
call it that those are your words not
mine
um we are we inqui we worked with them
to increase law enforcement at the
border to
deter uh the travel which is a
treacherous journey which where many
lose their lives
i think we have together thank you so
much okay
uh i don't have anything to preview for
you on the timeline okay thanks everyone
you